nuevo tiroteo en eeuu el episodio
ocurrió en el centro de sacramento la
capital del estado de california en una
zona de bares y restaurantes varias
personas murieron y una decena
resultaron heridas la policía hasta el
momento no ubica a los responsables
tenemos información muy limitada
alrededor de las 2 de la mañana la
policía patrullaba por la zona y
escucharon los disparos
y se acercaron al lugar y vieron una
gran multitud y vieron que
desafortunadamente varias personas
recibieron disparos de
los familiares de las víctimas llegaron
a la escena en busca de respuestas
soy una madre preocupada como otros
padres preocupados aquí sobre nuestros
hijos sólo quiero saber qué pasó o
what's como mamá según ganvam line
arkaitz este es el último tiroteo masivo
en eeuu donde las armas de fuego causan
al menos 40.000 muertes al año incluidos
suicidios este incidente se produce casi
un mes después de que un hombre se
quitara la vida en la misma ciudad luego
de matar a sus tres hijos y aún cuarta
persona en lo que va del año en eeuu se
registra 217 tiroteos en el año pasado
el sitio small arms and alice ha
reportado que se vendieron 20 millones
de armas en este país